not being shot at Dodger Stadium the
venue for that fight huh yeah we're
going to do something different you know
go you know Hometown Hometown Heroes you
know we wanted to do it somewhere Grand
La Outdoors make it a spectacle you tell
us about the movie that uh without
giving away who won I see I don't want
it we'll leave that to the Sharks
that's only for the most what can you
tell us Jonathan oh wow what can I tell
you um it's the third installment of the
Creed Three we're meeting Adonis Creed
uh and a brand new light uh and in the
movie we get to know things about him uh
about his past via brand new character
joining the Creed verse named Damien
Anderson
um it's intimate it's epic it's big it's
gladiatorial so so two questions number
one when you got to First Creed yep do
you have any excuse me any idea was
going to turn into three and secondly
you're directing this one yes sir so go
ahead and talk speak on that no I mean
for me and Ryan first did the first one
I had an idea that we could possibly do
more you know obviously you have like
you know six Rocky movies you know to be
able to do three three Creeds was
definitely an accomplishment and then
you know the third installment is
probably the most personal to me and at
that point I've lived with Adonis you
know over the last eight years and at
that point I felt like I was the only
person to be able to kind of step behind
the camera and direct it so I felt like
it was time for me to step in front of
the camp stepping behind the camera and
tell that story is this the first time
you directed first time I directed him
wow wow wow well you know I asked you
this question earlier because I said how
long have you guys known each other and
you were like this before before the
movie yeah so a couple years ago so
maybe like two and a half years ago but
y'all act like brothers yeah off the
camera it's so competitive this is all
that was going on on the camera but the
one thing they were talking about who
was the better athlete that's right it's
a better basketball player so you're on
Kenny's Court what's up so we got we got
we gonna do a shooting contest then we
could see who really wins the shoot live
okay both all both of y'all get five we
give you we give you free throw line
free throws
any five there and we'll see who who
makes the most out of five and before
you do that just will you answer a
question for me
just cause I'm curious when you're doing
these fight scenes yeah
how often do you make contact
unintentionally with each other
uh-huh one out of 20. I was going
against I was gonna do like maybe one
out of five because like body shots you
know body shots are good to go so those
those are all fairies what head shots
headshots you got to be a little more
methodical and strategic about you know
what I'm saying because like at least I
was no
because you know he was his first Creed
movie man we got to be initiated into
the world of creed so you got to take a
real Punch Yeah on Cree one I almost got
knocked out you know I'm saying so in
Creed Three you know he had to take a
real punch especially when we're doing
slow-mo shots because you can't fake
those you know I mean you can't fake
those the other ones we time them we
slip we know what's coming so you're
able to kind of move out the right way
move out the way in the right in the
right at the right time so uh but but
it's real contact yeah and I know he's
not here to defend himself or give his
side of it Shaq being sick tonight but
there was a a heavyweight bout between
Charles Barkley Illinois
and because you guys know the boxing
game so well you tell me who wins the
strike oh man I remember that punch it's
the phantom punch first is the ball boom
oh yeah oh yeah oh
foreign
[Applause]
let's go let's go that's rock and roll
with no warp with no warm up no it's no
ain't no warm-up on Kenny's Court
oh my God
that wasn't pretty
[Music]
now oh you back it up oh my God
are you coming back okay all right let
me see
this is the real athlete only real
athletes could do this that's what I'm
talking about Jonathan come on now
okay he got to walk up oh for one it's
hard with no warm-up all with no warm-up
oh man oh yeah it's quiet in here all
right here we go the studio has gotten
quiet it's what all in two boys
team is ready the pressure is on the
concert we need a concentration shot we
got to see his face his face is locked
in it's probably gonna be eyes closed
it's locked in oh you're gonna do the
same to him that he did to you okay I
don't like it I don't like it deep
breaths I don't like it we better it is
three out of four I don't like it at all
he said he was better Hooper he said you
said this doesn't count this doesn't
count
say less
[Music]
we got our normal
we got our normal Kitty oh my God Kenny
oh I got one
no you didn't you didn't say it
oh man what are you talking about oh my
God
you can stand in front you just shot
your face
at least we both want to take that out
I'll take that one come on
come on
this is it I mean you hit now that's
four for four it's four four four four
what's up ladies and gentlemen oh it is
still save me it is Court Kenny save me
save me both the guys I'll take that
come on man
I appreciate that appreciate it thanks
for being here hey it's not a reflection
you know what else yes sir hey hey Kenny
what's up anybody here ever ever done a
movie with Michael B Jordan yeah Space
Jam thank you very much good night
everybody good night everybody thank you
I appreciate you how's the mic drop
moment I love it